das blöken der schafe zu hören
das zwitschern der vögel sonst erste
still insel pastorin alexandra hector
schreitet mit ein paar ihrer schäfchen
in den deich entlang schweigend einer
meditation
die 52-jährige hat lange in norderstedt
bei hamburg gearbeitet vor fünf jahren
ist sie nach pellworm gezogen tauschte
die großstadt gegen das inselleben mann
ist tatsächlich etwas ab von der wild
und auf pellworm ist es auch so sobald
man auf die fähre steigt entschleunigt
man auch als bewohnerinnen das ist eine
unglaubliche lebensqualität ein bisschen
abstand zu haben nicht so den trubel zu
haben
auf pellworm gibt es keine ampel kein
fußgängerüberweg
es gibt sogar wenig bürgersteige fällt
mir gerade ein also es ist wirklich
alles sehr anders keine
straßenbeleuchtung nachts ist es dunkel
ist richtig dunkel
man sieht die sterne und das ist auch
eine echte lebensqualität
[Musik]
tierisch entspannt
schafe weiden auf dem gleich für grasen
und vögel ziehen ihre runden
pellworm gehört den tieren und der natur
hektik ist hier ein fremdwort
der wurm ist die etwas unscheinbarer
außenseiterin unter den nordfriesischen
inseln nicht so modern wie süd
verwunschen die amrum oder vielfältig
wie für aber dafür hat pellworm etwas
ganz eigenes zu bieten nämlich ruhe ruhe
und nochmals ruhe
pellworm ist nach süd und für die
drittgrösste nordfriese schild und die
wohl unbekannteste und ungewöhnlichste
keine touristenmeile keine party zone
und vor allem keine sandstrand pellworm
liebhaber vermissen nichts davon
genießen stille und natur
denn warum ist wirklich die medizin also
wenn ich aus dieser großstadt komme und
hier her kommen schon auf der fähre
macht es klick wird der schalter
umgelegt und dann fällt alles ab und das
geht die ganze zeit so man kann wirklich
unglaublich abspann ja und das ist ich
denke das merken ganz viele allergene
sind sagen ein appell warum immer
gelungen schon alleine wegen der weiter
man kann hier sich auf dem deich stellen
und unwahrscheinlich weit gucken und man
kann aufs meer hinaus gucken und kann
alles loslassen und gerade so auch wenn
es mal stürmisch ist oder so es ist
wirklich sehr schön weil man sich selbst
sehr gut spüren kann
die ruhe die gelassenheit dass es alles
in gang langsamer geht hier weiß man um
6 sind die geschäfte zu ist es einfach
muss mich ein bisschen anders
organisieren aber es ist einfach ruhiger
also gelassen und doch steht die insel
unter stunden
grünen strom
[Musik]
der bürgerwindpark im norden der insel
insulaner wie cat letzten setzen bereits
seit jahrzehnten auf erneuerbare
energien während die energiewende
vielerorts in deutschland erst so
richtig in fahrt kommt vieles hier ist
ökologisch sinnvoll und seine heimat
ansonsten ganz einfach wundervoll
vielleicht unterschätzt worden auf
pellworm dass das ein besonderer fleck
ist die man wirklich entdecken sollte
man kann sehr viel natur erleben hier
und wir leben ja seit jeher mit der
natur und auch mit den naturgewalten und
zum beispiel wir stehen hier vor einer
windkraftanlage und wind haben die
menschen hier an der küste immer schon
genutzt
die aussicht von oben dem höchsten punkt
performance soll spektakulär also auf
die mühle fertig
über eine luke auf das dach der anlage
der charakter der insel lässt sich mit
einem blick erfassen weil wärme ist in
vieler hinsicht grün
es ist sehr gut platziert und akzeptiert
der grüne gedanke hier und hier kann man
auch sehen wie es funktioniert
die windräder die solarpanels wir haben
eine biogasanlage und ein drittel der
insel wird ökologisch bewirtschaftet die
edel ließ war zum beispiel der bio
bauernhof der familie wachsen schon
lange engagieren sich sophie und jakob
wachsen für mehr klimaschutz verklagten
gar mit unterstützung von
umweltverbänden die bundesregierung vor
dem bundesverfassungsgericht und sorgten
damit bundesweit für schlagzeilen die
probleme die der klimawandel mit sich
bringt die haben sie hier direkt vor der
haustür
was man auf jeden fall bemerkte sind
eben die wetter- extreme die mir werden
das ist eben von total nass und windig
kalt zu super heiß und trocken geht
und daran kann man eben am meisten
festmachen das merkt man natürlich in so
einem wandelbaren lebensraum wie auf
pellworm mitten im weltnaturerbe noch
viel mehr als woanders
und wenn wir jetzt aus
landwirtschaftlicher sicht geht muss man
eben einfach anfangen mehr für den
klimaschutz zu tun damit man überhaupt
noch hier arbeiten leben kann weil sonst
geht das fleckchen glück eben einfach
irgendwann verloren
die klimaschutzmaßnahmen der
bundesregierung gingen sophie und ihren
brüdern nicht weit genug
ein steigender meeresspiegel kann hier
auf den inseln schnell zur existenzfrage
und karlsruhe gab ihnen recht sophie
studiert landwirtschaft in kiel um
irgendwann auf dem hof der eltern
einzusteigen der kampf gegen den
klimawandel schon jetzt ein kampf um die
heimat ich fand das thema war mal so ein
bisschen so kann man machen muss man
aber nicht
vielleicht wenn man mal zeit und lust
hat kann man noch mal drüber reden und
das ist so funktioniert klimaschutz
einfach nicht und gerade dann war ja
auch so risikofreudig für future demos
und kurz danach wurde irgendwie dieses
klimaschutz gesetz erlassen und es war
schon ein bisschen ja auch als wenn man
das ganze immer noch nicht so richtig
ernst obwohl millionen menschen in
deutschland auf der straße waren und
dann haben wir gesagt okay da muss man
vielleicht irgendwie anders rangehen
[Musik]
kurz vor acht uhr morgens
am anleger hoch affäre ist gms gebrüder
vertäut das ausflugsschiff der familie
mit einer handvoll gästen geht es hinaus
ins wattenmeer zum norderoog sagt eine
riesige sandbank mitten in der nacht
den blick aufs wasser und seine bewohner
die nase im wind das hatten die brüder
hellmann schon immer johann und andreas
sind auch bei wurden geboren und mit dem
watt und der weite groß geworden und
dann gehört man noch nicht ganz dazu
ureinwohner von fall war
der muss schon vor 1634 die schwere
sturmflut war propeller und
auseinandergebrochen sein ist jetzt
sozusagen da gewesen sein die familie
früher haben die hell männer wie sie auf
pellworm genannt werden
selbst mit ihrem kleinen kutter krabben
gefischt heute schippern sie tourist im
trüben fischen sie dennoch kleiner
zwischenstopp auf sie krabbeln gibt es
heute nicht aber eine kiste plattfisch
geht von bord
man kennt sich man hilft sich auf bei
wurm frischer geht's nicht direkt vom
kutter und das sind niesen sachschaden
nennt man die auch aber sonst bei den
touristen werden die als mutter tish
oder sand vorverkauf weil das hört sich
erzählt dass er an als klischees und
dann neuland betrieben oder ob eine
insel im entstehen begriffen jemand darf
dorthin nur die hellmanns haben
[Musik]
es lohnt sich genauer hinzusehen
wer sucht findet chronik farbene brocken
immer wieder wird bernstein angespielt
in den wintermonaten wenn schwere stürme
sind haben wir mit unserem boot hier
extra aus und gehen hier den gezielt
bern stand suchen konnte schon mal vor
dass also zwei hände voll ganz schön
haben wir zu bekommen bernstein münzen
und vieles mehr
überhaupt es norderoog sei ein
wunderbarer ort für fundsachen aller art
es gibt eigentlich nichts was ich nicht
gefunden habe aber das beste was ich
gefunden habe
hier am strand ist meine frau die habe
ich hier am strand gefunden ja
für die ging es dann von baden
württemberg nach pellworm
für uns geht es zurück an bord neue
heimat peru auch für alexandra hätte das
sind gerade mal 37 quadratkilometer
jeder kennt hier jeden und als pastorin
ist sie ansprechpartnerin für alle die
insellage die abgeschiedenheit die enge
einfach mal abtauchen das geht hier
nicht eine unserer ältesten
mitbewohnerin sagte mal zu mir weißt du
wir sprechen sehr gut platz ganz gut
hochdeutsch aber fließend über andere
und da ist was dran
ja also es ist ein sehr kleiner kosmos
wenn man möchte dass etwas auf pellworm
nicht öffentlich wird soll man es lassen
alles was du tust wird öffentlich das
ist der schatten ja man kann sich hier
nirgendwo verstecken es gibt kein
versteck auf pellworm
aber die menschen sind auf der anderen
seite sehr milde mit einem also hier
wird selten mit steinen geschmissen ist
ja man hat wirklich was verbockt
ansonsten sind sie damit vorsichtig weil
sie wissen beim nächsten mal sind sie
selbst dran
hell warm das heißt hier und da ein paar
häuser der nächste nachbar ist dorf
einige hundert meter entfernt
die insel hat sich ihren ländlichen
charme bewahrt
kaum einer kennt sie so gut wie knut
hier wurde er geboren hier ist er
aufgewachsen mein leben in der stadt kam
für ihn nie in frage andere gerade die
jüngeren zieht es wegen fehlender
perspektiven weg aus wetzlar mich ist
das halt heimat ich bin hier
aufgewachsen aber warum hat mir als kind
besser gefallen
das hat sich doch sehr viel verändert
sehr viel gebaut und das publikum hat
sich ein bisschen geändert
aber man kann hier eigentlich gut leben
knut nutzen ist deutschlands einzige vad
post oder zweimal wöchentlich läuft der
von pellworm hin zur nahen heilig süder
hoch um die vier bewohner dort mit post
zu versorgen
knapp sieben kilometer wir nun zurück
vier stunden hat er bei niedrigwasser
dafür zeit
aussuchen kann er sich seine arbeitszeit
nicht erbe und flut diktieren die
abläufe jede tour ist für ihn
einzigartig und das wattenmeer ändert
sich mit jeder tiere ans aufhören denkt
der 66-jährige nicht postzustellung im
rhythmus der gezeiten und das bei fast
jedem wetter
je nachdem ob man jetzt alleine läuft
oder mit mit wattwanderer man alleine
läuft kann man mal wirklich abschalten
man kann nur durch seele baumeln lassen
kann sie landet dinge denken das laufen
geht von selbst ist schon je nach
witterung jetzt wenn jetzt sturm ist und
wirklich fliegen dann ist natürlich
nicht so schön aber muss man aufgerufen
die post geht ab und die schafe sind los
das wars auf taiwan
keine hektik kein trubel
wiesn
wat und weit
[Musik]